what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so continuing on our journey with
the hunt for Wolverine we pick up now
with with weapon lost and again this is
this is kind of cool so so if those you
guys were just joining like the hunt for
Wolverine cost of the hunt for wine
story what this basically is is it's for
four-issue miniseries so 16 issues total
and it basically covers the hunt for
Wolverine from three different
perspectives right because all that all
that came out of the hunt for Wolverine
one shot where basically you ended up
learning that like the original
Wolverine the classic Wolverine has
basically been resurrected and
everybody's trying to figure out where
he's at and so were we originally
covered adamantium agenda I think which
covered with what's dealt with like like
Luke Cage and an Iron Man and those
characters this switch is over and
initially begins with daredevil meeting
with a guy named Frank McGee now Frank
McGee was one of these characters of
Marvel introduced really was introduced
by Charles Soule it was designed to
capitalize Lee's I'm pretty sure it was
Charles Soule whoever wrote the Inhumans
stories which was designed to capitalize
on the aftermath of infinity Thanos who
fought Black Bolt Black Bolt detonated
the Terrigen bomb and has spread the
Terrigen mists throughout the world
which began waking up all these Inhumans
Marvel and turned followed that up with
inhumanity and then inhuman and that was
designed to go through and basically
tell the story of like all these new and
humans that are waking up it was the
early stages of Marvel's attempts to
like replace x-men with the Inhumans
which we know proved to be disastrous
and so with this whole thing happening
Frank McGee was one of those guys he was
one of those individuals who was woken
up by terrigenesis now there came a
point when uh when he basically left and
then he went to go join the Inhumans and
became part of their special security
force and then eventually left after his
partner was killed and so what this did
is it led to him working alongside
daredevil to try to expose Wilson Fisk
who had been elected to the to the
position of mayor in in New York and
that's actually kind of a cool story
mayor Fisk if you guys haven't read that
yet how's a cool story there are some
stories that come out of Marvel Comics I
never cover and I just read it for the
sake of having it on my own
ah but still what we end up doing is
having Frank basically revealing this
stuff to daredevil that he's got like
huge files and huge databases on like a
massive amount of the superhero
community now again if he was just a
regular street cop he probably would be
able to say this but going through and
reading through all those files he
memorizes them all and so because that
his mind is like this almost you know
neuron your infinite database of
information but the problem here is that
when daredevil approaches Frank and says
look what we're looking for is Wolverine
that's when frames just kind of like oh
because it's not just a small time thing
it's not literally like a fish that you
throw out in the city of New York and
then you rake a man you wake Wolverine
in over the course of like two or three
days this is a global
thing it's across the world he could be
anywhere on the planet and that's one of
the things that people tend to forget
when it comes to when it comes to Logan
is over the years he's best known as the
guy who just puffs his claws and rips
things up but a lot of people tend to
forget he has decades of experience when
it comes to like stealth and guile and
espionage ninja tactics if he wants to
disappear he will disappear and so what
they end up doing the two of them they
actually go and they travel to visit
with and meet with misty Knight
now misty Knight the reason why this
works is because she's the other half of
the equation right there actually a
fourth member who'll join their group
but one of the things that people also
tend to forget about misty is yes she's
a private investigator but she made a
lot of contacts with the underground
when she was a cop and she's maintained
those contacts as a private investigator
then when she did lead the newer version
of Heroes for Hire that you saw during
civil war a lot of that stuff came to it
came to bear like you know when you had
crawling wing and you had misty night
and you had shang-chi like all that came
to bear and using like her various
tactics contacts and so on and so forth
especially when Tony Stark came to her
and said I'm looking for Captain America
he's on the ground your job is to find
him that when it comes to misty she's a
very very valuable resource in Marvel
Comics and so literally what this turns
into is all three of them kind of
working together and then literally
taking off and they end up Gordon New
Jersey Sal's gonna take offense to this
there because they make New Jersey look
like it look like it sucks I'm curious
Malthus for those of you who have lived
in New Jersey or you live in New York
whatever the case may be how do people
in New York view New Jersey and how do
people in New Jersey view in New York
why do people in Jersey hate New Yorkers
and do people in New York hate hate
people from New Jersey I have no idea
let me know because I'm kind of curious
I'm kind of curious what you guys you
know how that how that whole thing
unfolds but what they're doing is
they're basically traveling to like this
rundown ramshackle house that daredevil
can't see into because of all the
electromagnetic interference and we end
up finding out the person they're
meeting is a guy by the name of cypher
now for those of you guys who don't know
cypher is an old-school character he
goes all the way back to New Mutants
number 13 I think it was in cod 1984
he's old-school cipher has the ability
to basically decipher any language like
any light like any language he hears he
could pick up on and learn it now cipher
has like a weird and tumultuous history
in the late 1980s reshuffling of the New
Mutants line of comics under Louise
Simonson they killed off cypher and New
Mutants in number 60 and he stayed dead
for over 20 years he didn't come back
until action to crochet in like 2008
2009 when you ended up having like the
return of Celine and it was in the newer
x-factor
Comics x-factor vol 3 and I can't really
exact issue off top my head but he ended
up making his return but what ciphers
been doing all this time is putting his
abilities put in his mutant power to the
use and trying to like understand the
internet trying to basically figure the
internet out categorize it quantify it
and make order out of it the problem is
that the Internet is like is the last
bastion of unadulterated free speech
without consequence
meaning the Internet is in and of itself
an absolute cesspool of madness and so
because of this what ciphers been doing
it has been basically trying to like
understand the mind of the Joker is
really what this comes down to and it's
quite literally driven him to the point
of almost complete insanity now his
mind's not totally broken but what this
does is it turns into like an addiction
form because you have like daredevil who
throws his baton they talk some sense
into him they take him out to get a
hamburger but he's constantly jonesing
like he's constantly jonesing for access
to the Internet he has to always be on
the internet all the time otherwise
he'll end up losing his mind and going
insane and you know just like literally
as his fix is his heroin is crack
cocaine is his drug of choice and so
once they bring him out they say fine
what will let you have it in small doses
so they get a smartphone and they say
your job is to find Wolverine and he
starts combing through all these
different things what we end up finding
out is there's actually like a kind of
website that exists out there that does
nothing more than highlight like
Wolverine sightings like this is where
I've seen him this is where I've seen
him all these different stories that
people post online and it really does
get kind of bonkers if we're being
honest with ourselves it does get kind
of crazy and so from here because there
have been all these all these sightings
what this does is it turns quite
literally in like a cat-and-mouse game
it is Wolverine who's constantly on the
move and it's you know basically this
group of folks who are trying to find
him now what the end up doing is
traveling out to Saskatchewan Canada and
the reason why is because while all this
was going on they basically picked up on
kind of like a homing signal like a like
an SOS more or less like a cry for help
and zoning it on it they basically gone
to this location only to find out that
everybody in it is dead and so where you
end up having misty night and you have
daredevil and you have Frank and you
have a cipher who respond what this does
is it turns into cipher going back into
the house to do some investigating and
actually steal one of the phones of the
guards only to have his throat slit by
Wolverine and so it gets kind of crazy
so from there you basically have
everybody who just kind of comes racing
back right like as soon as that happens
daredevil picks up on the increased
heart rate of cypher realizes he's not
there and then realizes something
happened to him so racing back to the
house this leads to an all-out fight
between and daredevil and Wolverine
Wolverine just like takes off running
and daredevil chases after him now
when things begin to shift because what
we end up finding out here is this is
not actually Logan this is Albert now
Albert is OG I mean he's not like super
og he's not New Mutants OG but Albert's
old school so when Chris Claremont was
writing the x-men 4 you know since from
like 1975 going up until around 1992
when he left he wrote like a ton of
stories had like a lot of parts going on
but Chris Claremont leaving was like
that it was it was sudden it was just
like peace and he was out that was
basically there was no real notice or
anything and then Jim Lee follows
shortly behind him but when Piermont
left there are a lot of plot threads
that were left hanging and so the role
of like various writers Scott Liddell
and larry Hama really layer how am I
think was an editor editor in chief at
the time there was a point in Marvel for
like three years going from the late
1980s into the early 1990s I think when
they had no editor in chief there was
nobody running the show except for the
people all the way at the top which kind
of explains the comic bust in the 1990s
at least for Marvel anyway but what
ended up happening is the idea was we
have to wrap up a lot of these loose
plot threads and so what we ended up
having is back in Wolverine vol 1 issue
number 221 I think it was you had the
introduction of Albert and Albert was
created by Donald Pierce now Donald
Pierce was a holdover from the Claremont
era
Donald Pierce was introduced as a member
of the Hellfire Club he was part cyborg
he hated mutants averaged the Hellfire
Club was defeated he was ousted and
joined the Reavers and the Reavers were
just like this group of cyborgs is
basically all they were and so when that
happened there came a point when he
wanted to defeat Wolverine and so what
he did is he created two artificial
intelligence robots the first was Albert
and the second was LCD the problem with
this was that with LCD I want to say
that one of the guards of Donald Pierce
left the machine running but whatever it
was it happened she basically became
self-aware and when she did she realized
that her mission was to find will rain
and then detonate herself if Albert
couldn't do it and so what she did is
she woke Albert up and basically made
him self-aware and the two of them went
together is like a father and a daughter
more or less it was kind of like the
relationship that was formed was a
father-daughter relationship so they
survived that goes into the comedy bust
of the mid-1990s and they basically
vanished Mort was just kind of like
forget about it whatever and then now
they've resurfaced again and so LCDs
gone somewhere no one knows where she
went to and Albert's convinced as
somebody took her from them or someone
along those lines but it's just one of
those weird things where you have like
the robot version of Wolverine and he's
actually pretty I mean he's pretty
comparable to Wolverine himself far more
dangerous than like daredevil is or
anybody like that him he's got a bit of
a healing factor he's got metal claws
and so on and so forth
long and short of what you would expect
for somebody who is basically an
imperfect clone of Wolverine in
cybernetic form and so where you end up
having Gary devil who tracks him down
daredevil is able to get the upper hand
but the reason for this is because
Albert's not looking to kill him
Albert's looking to get out of there and
go find lcd if this was a fight where
Albert was looking to kill daredevil no
contest he would have tore him to shreds
I mean it would have been an absolutely
absolute massacre and so that's the only
reason daredevil was able to get the
upper hand on it and so this basically
leads to site for intervening and then
shooting
Albert in the back of the head and then
taking him out there so from here they
end up transitioning over to you know
flying back and trying to just kind of
figure out what leads they can grab from
there because at this point it's been
nothing but dead ends when they thought
they found Wolverine they didn't find
anybody at all so a cipher starts
searching on the phones of one of the
guards and when he does he ends up
finding out that there was basically an
apartment whereby one of the quote
unquote Wolverine sightings were seen
and the guy who this was an entire life
social media was his whole life I ended
up basically bailing out and so at the
same time you know when he took his post
down all the information was gone
everything about him just vanished on
the face of the earth when they get to
the building not only is he dead but
then you also have Frank who kicks in
and says look this guy he works for some
kind of agency he works for a group
called cetera at least I think it's what
it's called so tira ah but he works for
like this clandestine organization that
exists out there now as far as I'm aware
so tears a new creation a new
organization and so it gets kind of cool
because you end up having like these
various guys you have these various
people who were saved by daredevil the
rest are basically rescued by Frank and
Frank McGee misty Knight and so on and
so forth but when he starts analyzing
these bodies what this does is this
leads directly into them traveling to
the safe house of cetera and when they
enter there they're met with like a
level 4 kill team now for those you guys
who don't know Marvel Comics the level 4
kill teams that's a general designation
used by Marvel Comics and that's
designed to basically say like this is a
kill team at it that's like of the
highest here they shoot to kill when
they're sent in everybody dies
like everybody gets killed innocents
they're guilty the whole nine yards it's
one of those things that you use when
you want to like cleanse an entire
facility you sit in a level for kill
team and take them all out but I wanted
to kind of mention that because the way
that this kind of goes down and the way
it's explained it almost seems like a
particular team you know like a
particular organization that sent in to
take things out like the hand or
something like that not the case it's
just a general designation that's used
here but for the most part they're taken
out by like misty and I they're taken
out by like daredevil and Frank and so
on so you end up having cypher who
breaks into their computers which are
actually deleting themselves as he's
trying to search through all their files
and when he does he has a fine
like all these database recordings all
these things works like all these
extreme acts of violence and terror and
so on that had been perpetuated by so
tera and they have their hands on
Wolverine and when the question is asked
what will you do for us full range
responses whatever you want and so what
it looks like is that let Logan has for
whatever reason been thrown into the
Mitch of this extreme organization this
taking out people left and right now we
don't know what the what the motives
behind Sottero are we don't know what
their basis is they could very much be
like the hand because of the fact that
the hand is an organization that
Wolverine has had a lot of involvement
with those guys who don't know the hand
was a group that was originally founded
by a cog and Aubry Yoshioka and that
goes all the way back to like feudal
Japan when you had various farmers and
and poorer members of society who broke
away from like the existing Japanese
Empire at the time and then like went to
the mountains to go practice their own
form of martial arts neon ninja to
different things like that
and because they were all scattered they
were just you know various tribes
existing in a generalized location a cog
a know who brought them all together and
christened them all the hand now that
capitalizes on the fact that the hand
used to worship the Great Beast back in
the day ah which is actually the basis
behind shadow and shadow land was so
good but do you like I'm really hoping
they do that in daredevil season and
like some daredevil season do daredevil
season 3 is like two days away meant
that hype train man meant a heart trend
I don't they're doing daredevil born
again we need to cover that we need a
cover daredevil born again for daredevil
season 3 I keep forgetting about that
anyway anyway when it comes to that kind
of organization the hand no pun intended
they have their hands and everything but
this group may be exactly like that
which is how it appears to be so terror
seems to be almost exactly like the hand
in the sense that they're not like based
on ninja you know ninjas and magic and
resurrecting the dead but they are like
an extreme clandestine organization are
dying to take out various threats of
different things like that so it is kind
of cool but yeah if you guys are new
here to come this explain make sure you
guys are the sub button to become part
of the rob4 if you guys enjoyed this
video
make sure you drop a like and yeah I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Music]
you